all right guys
bang bang i've got chris here with me
thanks for doing this man of course man
thanks for having me
all right you've got one of the craziest
stories that i know uh
and there's a lot of similarities i
think between what you started doing and
what you're doing now and investing
but on the surface most people wouldn't
understand that
uh let's just start from like the very
beginning you are
how old before you start a talent
management business 20
years old and at 20 you're trying to
figure out like what you want to do or
you always knew you want to go into
talent managers
no really had no idea stumbled into it i
was on the path to become an athlete
tried to become a professional athlete i
was division one soccer player
learned really quickly that wasn't going
to work out after my sophomore season
kind of cold turkey dropped it and was
like okay what's next right
you go through that soul searching for
me it was like okay
what am i passionate about outside of
this sport
it was music was the answer for me and
okay how do i get involved with music
landed on talent management i would go
to barnes noble kind of just read music
business books to learn about it i
landed on talent management because i
was like okay there's no barrier to
entry here if i can find talent
and break that talent that's my foot in
the door so literally just stumbled into
it
all right and so when you start
understanding that uh was there things
you learned by reading like the talent
management
books or the like business books that
you were like okay here's like the two
or three things i got to do this
or was it literally just like just find
the right person it was more for me it
was more about finding the right person
and looking back now
if i had tried to educate myself on
that current music business back in 2010
2011
i think i would have been brainwashed
right i think a piece of my success was
not having the experience so i got to i
understood the internet and i understood
okay
where audience was where attention was
and i knew how to put my artist in front
of them
that was kind of how we broke through
and it was also a really unique time in
the music business
the recorded piece of music was kind of
dying these labels were having a really
rough time
because that was the era where everybody
was pirating music right and it allowed
me
and it really because i understood the
inertia where i lived that's how i found
talent there was this
these music blogs right it was this we
call it the blog errors a huge
uh piece of the music business people my
age i kind of came up with it
is this like dat piff in like a bunch of
those sites that's a great example but
it was more like college kids curated
blogs right
okay where they identify talent find
talent and post the talent and you would
just go to discover up-and-coming talent
that's where i found my artist and i had
a relationship with these kids
that's how i marketed them it was it was
that simple and executives didn't
understand it experience managers didn't
understand it
yeah and so when you say they didn't
understand it they didn't know it
existed they didn't know it existed i
was getting calls in the early days of
managing logic from executives that i
had started building a relationship with
and i'd have a video and it'd have 500
000 views after 48 hours you're like yo
how are you doing this
they were dumbfounded and what were you
doing i was
using those websites it was just
relationships right it was that
because people were checking those
websites and then again word of mouth
kicked in this was
the internet wasn't as noisy then and i
think that was a really special time
so if you discovered logic right you'd
want to go deeper
you went through his entire discography
right you told your friends about it
it's also the aux cord era where
everybody was sharing music whether at a
pre-game you're driving your car
and i just noticed word of mouth that
spreads so quickly
talk me through when you first found
logic is that the first artist that you
found
or is that just the first major artist
that the second artist ever worked with
there's
a rapper out of philly prior to that but
it was the first success i ever had
came across him on the internet um
really didn't have much music out
it was like an acapella video of him
rapping on the university of maryland
campus he lived in maryland at the time
and i kind of cold reached out to him on
facebook and i was like hey this
facebook message slide right in the dms
it's like what's up man he'd even have
an artist page i'd have found like his
personal facebook
that's how early it was yep reached out
to him and was like hey
you know i think you're talented i'd
love to manage you and a lot of people
did he know what that was
he did but he called me and he was like
you don't have any experience
and i was like i know that give me a
shot like just trust me
that's kind of the agreement that we had
i was like don't worry about paperwork
just give me a shot and and it you know
fortunately worked out
so you see him uh was there anything
that you were like
like this guy's a star in the making was
it sure lyrics was it just like kind of
like stage presence if you will or was
it just
literally intuition like i don't know i
can't explain it but like this guy's
real
it was more intuition from i think me
being such a fan of hip-hop
i was like okay this kid is a student of
the game right this kid has worked at
his craft that that's what stood out to
me
you could tell that by watching right
away yeah right and then obviously got
to know him more and more and hear more
music i'm like okay that was very true
um so that kind of was what drew me to
him and once you guys decide like all
right let's work together
this is 2011 2011. okay so in 2011
uh social media is not huge right like
very very different world you've already
described
what do you do because you basically
take a kid that you find in maryland who
nobody knows
and it becomes logic right and for all
intents and purposes that's like a zero
to one type event uh
that doesn't happen overnight like what
are the steps kind of from an execution
standpoint you guys did
to take logic's talent and actually make
it this household name
sure knowing what i understood and
i think like i said a couple minutes ago
i understood the internet and i
understood where attention was right
and had the relationship with all these
blogs and again at the time you couldn't
even really get
behind the scene analytics so i would
just again it was all intuition i was
like okay
i would reverse engineer other artist
breaking okay okay youtube seems to be
uh playing a big role in this artist's
career so i would sit logic down like
hey we need to shoot a music video for
almost every song on this project right
because that that's really how we're
gonna market you and we'd roll it out
slowly as
kind of singles but there'd be five or
six off of mixtape because youtube was
that was really the only music streaming
platform if you think about it right
this is pre-spotify pre-apple music
so as a way for kids to easily share
music when you post on your facebook at
the time it would clean embed
in in facebook so you could watch it
across your news feed
twitter did the same thing at the time
so we shot a video for every single
single that we hand-picked um and it was
low budget like i
we would i would bargain with directors
there's one directory worker's name was
gravity
i was like hey i'll let you put your
logo at the beginning of the video
because we don't have a budget to pay
you and that was the trade-off um
and so that was equal because that
person's betting my work plus logic's
talent is going to be a viral
video and right we started getting you
know some great views at the time so it
was worth it to him at the point and we
ended up growing and building with that
kid for a couple years
um so it was just figuring it out and
and think you know again
intuition where i thought talent was
going to be putting logic there
and then word of mouth just did its
thing and started to take off okay so
word of mouth kind of did its thing
right
we've talked quite a bit about how you
kind of uh methodically built
a really really rabid fan base and
for those that aren't familiar with
logic's fan base there's like i don't
know uh the drakes and the jay-z's and
like these
massive massive names and yes they have
some subset that
care a lot but on a percentage basis
majority of their audience is more of a
passive kind of listener
sure right it's hey i like jay-z's music
but if jay-z comes to town
i'm not literally gonna not go to my
brother's birthday party to go
right right logic actually has a very
high percentage of his audience that
literally will do anything that he is
doing or into or whatever
because it's almost like a measurement
of engagement right right it's not
passive it's much more kind of
intentional so
one of the things you told me before is
you guys would go on these city by city
tours
and it sounds like it would start out
really really small and then you
basically would just like okay the next
time we come like
increase it like walk through like why
did you go on the city tours and like
how did you actually
execute that yeah the quick answer was a
way to monetize his audience because at
that time we were giving away free music
so we weren't making any money off of it
and i think back to your prior question
it didn't happen overnight it was what
we focused on him i talked about it
every day
we'd say small wins so that's what kind
of got me up in the morning i was like
okay let's get a small win today
right because i started to see it day by
day it was compounding i'm like okay
this is kind of really happening right
so you wouldn't have this major viral
moment
but every single day i'd refresh the
video and have more views i look at the
streams it'd be more streams
i look at the social followers to be
more and then i realized it started
compounding
at a higher growth rate as time went on
and then i was like okay i think it was
all intuition based we didn't have data
like i said the way you get like
spotify has a back end that is just
[ __ ] incredible gives you so much
information
where the listeners are coming from the
age of that listener so you know your
entire audience demographic right you
know where they are where they're
consuming your music
we had no clue so it was an intuition
thing where i'm like i remember calling
him
i'm like i think we could probably tour
right
and again learning as we went throwing
the tour together i think we did 35
cities on that first run
um rented uh minivan and nissan altima
and jammed them and toured the country
man what does that mean when you go on a
tour like
like do you go to a park do you go to
like a bar like
we were doing we were doing probably 250
to 350 cap room so very small rooms
right
we had no tour history and it was all of
us working with promoters
and we had an agent that we work at the
time nobody would give us guarantees so
the way touring business works
is you'll get a flat guarantee you do
really well you'll get back in right
because logic had no tour history nobody
wanted to give us guaranteed so that
like a guarantee would be like hey come
here and play we'll pay you
you know ten thousand dollars to play
and then oh by the way if you hit some
metric
then we'll cut you another check for 10k
so you can make up to 20 000
for playing tonight but 10 is up front
guaranteed
the other 10 is you got to you gotta
pull in the audience exactly that so
we embarked on this tour again no
guarantee so like it didn't work out we
lost
we lost literally everything so to
backtrack a little bit
the way we had the startup capital so we
bootstrapped the business
my management company never raised money
we had to sign a record deal
in order to fund that first tour right
so we
literally brit like i was like hey logic
i'll put my advance in he put
me and him split the money we went on
tour and it just worked out and it was
figuring it out as we went
i had never toured before obviously and
you know even the accounting was just
like i look back at it i'm embarrassed
now but it's telling the cash story the
cash story is so good
so again being a door deal you'd settle
the end of the night in cash depending
how
the tour did and we crushed we ended up
all right just so people understand a
door deal basically means no guarantee
people are coming in you'll get 85 90 of
every ticket sold
okay so when people show up they're
literally paying cash
they're getting a ticket they're walking
inside but that cash that they just paid
is ultimately supposed to end up in your
pocket 80 85 90 whatever
but it's sitting in cash which you know
depending who's at the door
depending on what the the uh venue is
gets kind of sketchy if all of a sudden
cash starts disappearing or whatever so
my accounting system at the time right
before we went on a tour i
had manila envelopes i'm like all right
35 cities denver colorado i'd ride on
huge right
and i'd have it in a backpack and i was
like the end of night i'm going to
settle and i'm going to literally it was
like a ledger and i would write
everything so if somebody need 20
for weed minus 20 for weed right and
we finish the entire tour when i say i
look back i'm embarrassed it was in that
one backpack right
we'd be in a green room i put it down in
the corner and we'd all leave the room
it's 65 70 000 and it's just cash yeah
and literally
all of the expenses of logic's tour is
written on manila envelopes everything
just in a backpack together everything
and then post [ __ ]
right we're at my house i was working
with harrison remler who you know now um
who's the ceo of my company at the time
was an intern
he ended up tour managing for me on that
tour i left i did the first 10 shows
kind of showed him the ropes so we're
literally my parents basement at the
time where
we built the business out of and we're
trying to then input everything into
like an excel spreadsheet and have it
neat because we had to bring the cash
into the bank
yeah yeah and they want to know where
the hell did you guys get this cash so
you're pulling out of a backpack
so so we literally we're sitting there
we're taking out the cash we're putting
the cash on top of the envelopes right
i was working in full time so it was all
it was all laid out on the floor so
you'd have denver and there'd be cash on
top of it you have new york city cash on
top of it
i was going to work so i was in college
working full time and managing logic at
the time
and i was like i hired finish up here
you got it i'll jump out i leave i come
back
okay he tried to clean up took all the
envelopes ripped them up throw them out
i get back there's just 35 pounds of
cash
so we had no idea so we had no idea
no idea what we should do just put on
the bank and just said hey we're gonna
i'll take my commission you get the rest
now is it yeah dude like it wasn't
glamorous back then
yeah and a lot of people think like oh
it's entertainment it's music business i
mean it was like
really hard work like just grit and and
like the tour
you're jam body to body in the bed like
i rode that minivan
like this yep and when we got back to
new york so we ended the tour in new
york
and we did everything like it wasn't by
the book i the the rentals were in my
name
so i rented them from long island and
rentals uh the cars the minivan in new
zealand
yep toured the country went to
california and came back and i was doing
the paperwork and it's like you can't
leave new york state
we literally drove across the country
and came back i was like well i'm gonna
return him in new york so who's gonna
know
meanwhile they're taking photos of our
license plate every easy pass and
everything it was uh
yeah so when you do that how much of the
success
of this first tour is because you guys
didn't do what everyone else did
versus know if we had done what everyone
else did we would have been way more
successful
no i think it wasn't the tour if we had
done what everyone else had done i don't
think we would have got logic's career
off the ground
okay it was it was doing things our way
that was kind of a little bit different
and that's why i was getting calls from
executives going yo how are you doing
this how are you building this audience
it was just solely living on the
internet like
a lot of times i say logic is kind of a
child of the internet we built his
entire career
on the internet by giving away free
product which again record executives
and labels look to me like we're nuts
it's like the one thing that you can
monetize you're giving away for free
and i would get frustrated because i'm
like you don't understand i'm building
an engaged audience
they're creating emotional connection
with this artist i'm not going anywhere
when it's time to monetize we'll
monetize right how important is it
uh building an audience on the
internet's one thing right you can go
you can tweet post on youtube whatever
uh versus actually going and seeing your
200 fans
in milwaukee wisconsin right and being
able to
either have them see you and and kind of
be there in person or even
signing things or taking photos with
them or like doing that type of
in person right like like is that
actually a really
key ingredient here versus just oh yeah
we were on the internet we were good at
the internet
but like we could have done it without
that in person that's a great question i
think back then it was so important we
were kind of in the dark on exactly
whose audience was because we didn't
have the data that you can get now right
we didn't know kind of the age demo we
didn't know you know
so that first tour was everything for me
i would go and generally be a balconier
i would just stare at these fans and i
go okay this is who his audience is
now let me try and go where they're
gonna be or where i think they're gonna
be and continue to market him
so that's kind of how we developed
everything from the beginning but now
you can build anything on the internet
and you have that information right
so you shouldn't be surprised when you
do sell a show out to see who's there
but back then it was like i had to learn
who was going to be there
yeah when you think about um the idea
of like okay i now understand who the
actual demographic is right
i'm assuming that it was like hey who's
democratic i don't know young right like
or
college or whatever it was uh but once
you start to understand
all right this is actually who these
people are what do you do to like
go figure out what else they like or go
and put him somewhere else right
because he doesn't have enough star
power at this time it sounds like to
like
walk in and do deals and do all this
kind of crazy stuff
it's still a lot of like guerrilla
marketing but it's not just around music
it's really kind of building this like
cultural uh kind of trend around an
individual
very much so i think you had to try and
really understand who that audience was
who else they'd listened to
what they consumed um you know even
lifestyle brands we did a deal early
on with fila right which was kind of an
old
you know sports brand that was trying to
you know have a resurgence
and it made a lot of sense for logic's
brand at the time he's not a high-end
street fashion dude right it would have
made sense back then to do a deal with
supreme right
um it was funny as we started to see it
these kids also kind of live vicariously
through him
so in one of the tours when we did that
deal i started seeing kids show up and
feel it gear every day
right so it was kind of cool and i
realized okay this is more than just
kind of a fan base this is kind of like
it's a lifestyle type
thing for him but yeah i think
understanding who your audience is the
most important thing you can do and then
tripling and doubling down
on over delivering to that audience and
a lot of people can say they did that
we live that i think logic you know as
an artist probably has some of the best
examples of doing that
his sophomore album it was literally
that how can we continue to double down
how can we continue and from the
earliest days right
uh again and where i keep saying future
trends and predicting and putting him
there
he was he lived on ustream right and
this is a decade ago
now you talk about twitch right and we
just did a twitch deal a decade later
we were live streaming to with to his
fans 10 years ago
he'd sit on twitter go on ustream and
engage with these kids it'd be 35 kids
there right
but that's what people don't understand
right just real quickly uh
when we talk about streaming or building
an audience he's not turning on one of
these platforms like oh there's ten
thousand people here
right you're talking about 35 [ __ ]
people on the other end of it
and it's day in and day out day in and
day out every day
he knew the early fans by their names
they still come to shows now
and i used to say to him at the time i'm
like that kid is going to
buy music buy merch buy tickets a decade
from now
and we've seen it play out right so he
lived on your stream taught he would
engage with
35 kids right so identifying you know
those trends and doing it but also
then saying okay as he started to get
bigger where that wasn't really possible
anymore it was too big
how can we continue to double down then
use social media as kind of a microphone
megaphone so his sophomore album it was
kind of him and i brainstorming how we
could do that
and i kind of came up with the idea i
was like what if we just kind of bust
you he lived in l.a at the time
need to be in new york for press and
media when his album came out two weeks
later
i was like what if we did a 14-day bus
tour where across the country we
literally stopped at fans houses
right we ran a contest stop the fans
houses knocked down their door
and you went inside and played them the
album one on one right you had that
experience before it came out
right and we captured that content and
we put that content out that's exactly
what we did i've never seen an artist do
something like that
how long was the album that album was
probably an hour and 20 minutes
so literally i'm gonna go into
somebody's house that i've never met
before but it's a fan of me
i'm gonna play the album i'm gonna
interact with them i'll spend an hour
and a half two hours whatever with them
and then i'm gonna go to the next one
that was one person
one person he showed up again and he
knocked on the door and again
and again we did it for two weeks
straight and ended up in new york when
the album came out
but it was such a cool moment because
then we document it
and logic would kind of post on social
media what that interaction was
hey this is jacob from san antonio texas
right jacob's 17 years old he's this
and would tell a little bit story they
had an interaction but that fan got a
moment they're gonna remember the rest
of her life
logic sat there not only played the
album one-on-one game a little bit
behind the scenes
hey this is my inspiration for the song
so i was going through in my life when i
made this song
and then kind of learning from that
experience and taking for me
and doing it again but trying to perfect
it even better with other clients
it's like my second client john bellion
who i'm still working with to this day
we did the same exact thing a year later
right really
but stepped it up a notch so he was
playing live in the living room we did
an entire acoustic show for that person
in their family
in their living room so it's like really
meaning it when we say doubling down and
over delivering to your audience
yeah and so when you start to think
about this uh
let's go back to logic for a second i
think everyone thinks of him initially
as
a musician right as a as a rapper
whatever you want but a performer
there's a lot of different facets to his
life
there's that aspect there's chess
right you start getting into the various
personalities or kind of
pseudonyms if you will write or kind of
brands around him talk about just
uh it's one thing to say okay you as a
performer i'm gonna take you i'm gonna
take you city to city we're gonna use
the internet we're gonna build an
audience and if we have audience and
fans then we can
figure out how to build a business
around you as a performer but you guys
built an entire franchise sure
right and there's multiple ways to look
at this like
where did that come from is that you
saying hey we should go build a whole
franchise is that just naturally kind of
okay here's the next
kind of step we take like how does that
come together it was
a learning experience as we kind of went
i think his
early days of logic if you look at a lot
of that first album was 2014 it was
called under pressure
even if you look he was on the double
excel freshman cover which is
you know for an up-and-coming artist
it's the biggest thing you can get it's
it's
basically predicting it's a who's next
list right and you go and you do that
big photo shoot for the cover
and if you look what logic's wearing
he's got you know a big jacket on
three four gold chains and it so wasn't
who he is right now we all know who
logic is he's not that guy
we had a stylist for the shoot we
thought we needed to fit
in the box of pop when logic really
lived on the outside of it and
once i realized that i just started
nudging him to be more and more of
himself
the more human and himself he became
those personas started getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and we were able
to kind of
build these different brands around him
because they were all part of him
right i think because he's a versatile
artist bobby tarantino one of his
personas
is like a little bit more fun right i
think young sinatra's boom bap hip hop
which
originally is what drew me when i
reached out to him um and then we also
built merchandise brands around those
personas and were able to really expand
you brought up him playing chess he had
an error where he kind of perfected a
rubik's cube
so he's going to do press and he's going
to freestyle at his radio station i'm
like yo just bring your group's cube
he started freestyling doing it with his
eyes closed you know
his sophomore album we did a panel at
comic-con because like we started
realizing some of his audience it was
kind of this nerd culture thing
it's like let's lean into it right and
looking back now i think he
kind of grew what hip-hop was and what's
acceptable in hip-hop because
he didn't fit in that box and if we had
continuously tried to put him in that
box
i think we would have failed miserably
so i think the biggest thing was
identifying that
learning from and saying listen let's
triple down on who you are
how important is it to have the right
person to do this with
oh it's so important right because if
you're not authentic in genuine that's
the biggest thing about logic he's
just such a genuine guy um i think
it would be impossible because i think
audience can see through that and a fan
base can see right through that and i
think they realize how genuine he was
like this dude's doing rubik's cube
because he loves it
this dude is playing chess on twitch now
versus grand masters because he loves it
you know
what's up guys before we continue with
this interview i want to quickly talk
about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses
so whether you're an og or this is your
first trade
kraken has all of the tools that you
need to achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in all
of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin
ethereum and many many more kraken also
provides in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today
again that's kraken.com bang bang all
right let's get back into this interview
i hope you're enjoying it
now what you've done is you've basically
built a talent management business right
and uh not once you've done it many
times with multiple artists
uh but you started to do more investing
sure
and i think when we first started
talking uh at first it's like okay
anyone who's successful at anything like
they want to have some investments but
the more that we've gotten to know each
other it feels like there's a really
really strong connection between
talent management and startup investing
because ultimately what you're doing is
you're picking talent sure right so talk
a little bit just about like
how do you see those similarities and
like is it literally
the same way i pick logic out of a crowd
i can go pick the next startup founder
that i think will have like a higher
probability of success
or is that not really a great comparison
i wouldn't say picking a startup founder
out of a crowd but i think when you
work with successful people right like
identifying logic and then doing it
several times over and building
you know a talent management company
you're like okay well maybe i have a
unique ability to identify talent right
and then the second aspect of that it's
not only identifying talent it's having
an a unique world view and knowing where
the world is going to be and putting
that artist there because that's how we
did everything when you're bootstrapping
a company
and you don't have hundreds of thousands
of millions of dollars in marketing
costs
you just had to outsmart everyone and
put that artist where the world was
going to be right they'd be a first
mover
anytime a social media application came
out logic was the first mover
he built a massive audience in the early
days of snapchat right
so it's it's using those two things and
as i grew over
the course of the decade i started
realizing about three years ago that
there's a lot of comparisons
as it was organic right people would
start introducing me to
you know startups and founders and
having the abilities okay this person
kind of has those
you know qualities of what some of the
artists that i invested in have and then
also
you know as they're pitching me
listening to that and going well
well i know where the world is moving
i'm going to bet on this so it's kind of
both those things
when it was kind of one of those moments
we're like wow there is really a lot of
similarities between these two things
once you find talent from a music
standpoint
you do a lot of work in terms of what
i'll call uh kind of behind the scenes
um really kind of helping them plot
what are the intentional steps we're
going to take to get the ultimate goal
right how does that play into then
helping a startup founder or a company
because it's very similar a lot of
investors you have to help from a
strategic standpoint you're not there
every day doing stuff
but just like how do you see the
experience you have from music
porting over yeah i think i can help in
in where i think
i understand the world the best and
that's kind of living in the
entertainment and tech space for a
decade
um building an audience right and i
think any startup at a certain point
needs to
needs to get users um so it's
over a decade of experience and also i
grew a business right
i bootstrapped a business and um i think
it's it's trying to add value in the
world that i know right if something
as i really can't add value and i tend
not to invest in it
um because i don't see the point i was
like i can't add you value
one of the areas of investing i think
that people are super interested in
today is this like creator economy
right um we've talked previously about
this idea of like what's the difference
between logic
the musician versus somebody who's a
twitch streamer versus somebody who's on
tick tock versus somebody who's got an
email newsletter versus a podcast versus
somebody who gets a netflix deal
they're all creating content they're all
trying to build fans right they're
trying to have engagement like all this
stuff
so how do you look at the evolution over
the last 10 years or so
since you started to today of like what
a creator is
and kind of all the tools and analytics
and stuff that are available to them
yeah i think most creators have always
been there but i don't think there was
the distribution channels for them to
kind of build an audience right and now
what you're seeing is kind of this
middle class emerge right
and one of the themes i've been obsessed
with the past couple years is
niche right because story about
it was actually the day i was always i
always knew logic was a niche artist
right
and we didn't care about having the big
pop culture moment
ultimately that came right but it was
like let's just triple down on this
audience that you have
he he sold out the garden right and that
was a big deal i'm a new york guy
and like any other morning i'm on my run
i lived in the east village at the time
i was in east river run
and i was running through the city and i
had a thought i was like
ninety-nine point nine percent of people
right now have no idea logic's playing
atmosphere tonight right
i was like so that is the pinnacle as an
entertainer selling out that arena right
but i realized like the eight million
people in the city
there's only 15 000 people in that room
tonight
that's a niche business right so it
started getting me to think more and
more about niche and then as
kind of the internet evolved tech
evolved like what you're seeing now is
the middle class economy just
boom i use an example as an analogy like
betty sue in north dakota
who bakes cookies on youtube with her
daughter and right and other moms with
their daughters watch them and they
use the same recipes she can actually
have a real business
like doing that now and can live off
youtube ad revenue and maybe sell
recipes
so i think if you have a but again the
one thing that i try to remind people
you have to be talented
you can't just turn on a microphone and
start a podcast
you have you have to be there's got to
be some talent there you have to be
adding value to an audience or else i
don't i don't think it'll it'll work
yeah and so when you're doing that that
is
uh again like more from the creator seat
what about the tools
right how has that stuff changed whereas
you know now
if you had the tools you have today back
in 2011
my guess is you guys would be even
bigger right you were already super
successful but like it would be even
bigger because it's just
leverage on the ideas that you have sure
there's
so many more ways now because of tools
that you can monetize and also build an
audience you just said like
whether it's an email paid email
newsletter whether it's a podcast right
when we started out a decade ago there
was very few ways you can do that
and now what i say to artists like
unfortunately you can't just make music
anymore i think music is just
it's an extension of your brand you have
to build your brand right
um and again it's easier for some people
based off their personalities than it is
with others like i think logic that
became natural right
pandemic happens and we're sitting there
go how do we generate revenue right
we're going to lose
x number of dollars in touring income i
knew the twitch executives we started
having conversations organically it
turned into a twitch deal right
and that was groundbreaking for twitch
at the time they'd never done a deal
with an artist before
um and because of who logic is he can
interact with his audience that way he's
playing chess on there
he'll he'll go and make beats for an
hour and kids love that right it's
i've been going to studio with him for
10 years i don't find it that
interesting anymore
kids love that right that's the
perspective they don't normally get
so i think now there's just so many ways
that if you're not
but again again a piece of advice do
what's natural to you
right if you're not a good writer don't
do a paid newsletter right if you're if
you're better speaking and on camera
do youtube vlogs and we were doing all
this stuff 10 years ago
from that first tour i mentioned a
decade ago we have vlogs on youtube you
go back and watch that entire tour
right like it's stuff we were doing it
10 years ago
and when you were doing it were you
measuring any of this
like in terms of like analytics or
success or like like
why keep doing it right it's one thing
to say oh this should be a good idea
what gives you the confidence to keep
doing it because it was growing so we
saw it and it was like small w
right okay this vlog this week did
better than last week's vlog
that's positive let's do it again and it
was like i said the small wins adding up
on a daily basis
again when you're first starting out to
this day it's no different you have to
see
growth and just let that keep you going
give the motivation to continue doing
what you're doing
if you go back what are the
tools today that you're like this was a
game changer for
artists whether they're musicians or
otherwise is it
just streaming for example like hey
whether it's twitch uh streaming video
streaming music on the spotify's apple
musics is it something else like what
are those inflection points now kind of
looking back that you're like man maybe
people didn't understand it at the time
but this really changed the game social
media social media
it's why you can take a kid from
maryland and me building out of my
parents basement we're both 20 years old
and you know completely get it off the
ground to where every single
record company is calling us asking us
how we were doing what we're doing
starting and you know selling on a
national tour he he sold out
three and a half national tours in
europe twice before you even put out his
debut album
everybody was heads they're like how did
you do this it was social media that was
completely game changing for for us is
there a corollary
in like the startup world uh to mixtapes
like mixtapes almost feel like a half
r d half uh customer acquisition
and then like half uh practice to some
degree right like
really well said yeah i agree i think i
guess that was three halves so you can't
really get a hold but go ahead
no but it was it was a way for us to see
what his audience liked
right those mixtapes were we had 22 23
songs they were big mixtapes and we got
to see what performed better
um what his audience engaged with and i
think as he developed
he was almost like it's a talent right
that's him in the gym working on his
free throw
but he's doing it publicly i think
learning in public is is something that
i advise a lot of people to do
um that's what that to me that's what
mixtapes is learning in public right
you're trying things you're figuring it
out
he was perfecting you know his skill um
and by the time he was ready for his
debut album i think it was because of
all of the
the mixtapes and music we had put out
yeah when you start to think through
uh investing are there certain things
you're looking for or is it just i'm
looking for the founder
more more often than not for me it's a
founder they have that again it's
intuition based right and this is
learning a lot how i've grown
so as an investor especially over the
course of the past three years
right i had took a bunch of early bets
in my life
right you know i bet my life on logic
and
john my first two clients and had just a
massive level of conviction in their
talent and then as i kind of had some
success i started taking smaller bets
and this is the investing space
not necessarily all in the startup world
betting in the public markets
and i was like okay i was right a lot
right but my upside wasn't tremendous
because i was taking these small bets
right
and it was something and we talked about
this right before that chamath
poly hapatia had talked about slugging
percentage versus batting average
right i had a really high batting
average but a lower slugging percentage
because i
wasn't taking these high conviction bets
playing not to lose
correct i was playing not to lose
instead of to win and i
i was funny because i was thinking on it
reese i was like why did i do that right
in my early days i took these massive
outsized bets right and had these
massive outside
wins but once i had some level of
success i was more timid and wasn't
willing to do that it was
i don't know it's something about kind
of human nature i think i fell into that
so i have to remind myself the next time
you feel that level of conviction
bet on that founder bet on that startup
bet on that right so that's
something i constantly remind myself
yeah and when that
happens in startups there's one check
size
right that you can write for sure but
two is it feels like you can be
really really helpful outside of just
the check because you've got a very
different kind of rolodex right
you have very different experiences than
kind of cookie cutter venture
capitalists who
hey you know they're great people they
work hard they're doing what they're
good at
but a lot of them have the same skill
sets a lot of them have the same
networks and so you bring something
differentiated to the table and that's
really where
you can leverage that on these big bets
sure so
again that's it's super important me to
add value i speak the founders that i
invest in i try to speak to them
every two weeks if not more and again
it's how much the founder wants to speak
to you and how much you're looking for
advice
um but yeah it's back to your previous
question
if it's the founder that same intuition
i got in some of my early clients
if i have that same feeling i'll take a
big bet yeah when you start thinking
about
uh how the startup ecosystem is changing
uh crypto is one piece of that there's
also just traditional technology
early stage private markets and then
there's like everything else and i'll
put everything else in like this legacy
bucket so there's real estate there's
public markets all stuff
it feels like you're much much more
focused on like early stage venture
and crypto more so than the other stuff
correct all right so walk me through
like where does that come from and like
how do you think about
okay i've got all these opportunities
that i could invest in across all these
different asset classes like why
those two for me and this is going to
sound like a
you know funny answer but the the
asymmetrical upside right i could
take my money and i could stick in s p
500 index fund and make six percent a
year
for the rest of my life right i enjoy
kind of betting on my gut
and betting on my world view because
there's no better feeling in the world
to me
than that and the closest example i you
and i start
to work right and me understanding again
my word i'm like okay
there's going to be an outcome from the
fed printing this much money
what i think that's going to be is
that's going to create inflation where
can i put
my money as an inflation hedge and then
i started going down
the bitcoin rabbit hole right and i went
to school consuming all of your content
and just literally
from reading the white paper to just
going deep um and then the final step
for me
was reaching into my network getting
introduced to people like yourself
getting introduced to fred ursum
co-founder of coinbase
getting you guys on the phone meeting
with you for a beer in new york and
going hey here's my thesis
do you think i'm right and once i heard
yes enough i was like okay i'm gonna
push all my chips in right and that's
that level of conviction um
and then kind of seeing the run that
bitcoin has had since
it's a great feeling right i use kind of
investing in business i'm a competitor
right back to my original from the
beginning athlete a soccer player so
it's a way for me to kind of get that
competition out a little bit
is competition what drives you like what
would you rather would you rather
win and say like yes i bet on this and i
was right
or would you rather actually make money
on something you were wrong on
that's a tough question but i think
about us all the time like what is the
right answer there
at this stage i'm just competing with
myself right
um i would
did you ask me if i want if i would i
feel better betting on something being
right and winning
betting on something being wrong and
winning would i feel better
definitely being right i think um
have i won off something that i was
unsure of but took that
bet sure um but yeah i think i'm
competing with myself when i was younger
i would like you know i think it's part
of what drove me i want to compete with
other managers and
executives um is there a lot of [ __ ]
talking that goes on and uh
no but i think behind the scenes you
kind of like nah we're gonna
you know let wait till we see that guy
what he's doing we see that woman when
she's doing like okay and that was the
young that was a younger entrepreneur in
me and i realized
you know a little a little bit later
that it's not a zero-sum game
and when i once i kind of that fl that
switch had flipped for me
i started winning much more what are one
or two ideas that you have now
that you're like if i'm a founder if i'm
an artist
i want to build an audience given all
the tools given the world we live in
today whatever what are one or two
things we were like
man i would go spend a lot more time on
a or b
but most people don't think about those
things right like it's almost like a
a counterintuitive thing to go spend
your time on but that you think that
there's a lot of payoff there
i think the best way i could answer that
is understanding where
your audience is it may not be the
biggest platform in the world like
so many artists want to run to tick-tock
right that is the thing right now and
it's been like that for a couple years
but it's like maybe your music isn't
right for tick-tock maybe you yourself
as a brand as an artist isn't
right for tick-tock why not spend a lot
of your time on discord
i think that's where your audience is
you should spend time on discord right
what does that mean like spend time on
discourse that like start your
own uh kind of discord uh yeah
based around your interest maybe right
and then be be the
the subject matter expert in that and
then also then pull people into your
music right
again music is just now an extension of
an artist's brand right
like maybe logic is the chess guy and
his music is just
you know extension of his brand right
obviously he was a bigger musician first
but i'm you can reverse engineer that
and say well no
i can be the this guy in this space and
then kind of just and again
the bad example of it is a lot of these
tick tock kids putting out music it's
not what i mean
like it has to be is it not good no
comment it has to be authentic and
genuine to who you are but there's just
so many ways that like
and what i'm realizing now right is
people want to go deep
not the same way they used to go deep
back when i was starting out a decade
ago because the internet wasn't as
noisy right so what i challenged myself
and i challenged my team
where can we put our talent to where
people are going to want to go deeper
tick tock you just scroll next next next
next neck
it's so hard for you to stop click on
that artist profile go a little deeper
then go to their spotify page
now 10 years ago that's all you really
did and i re that's why i say word of
mouth right it's something that i focus
on a lot because people don't talk about
it because you can't it's a metric you
can't measure
but i'm like where can i put talent to
where word of mouth is going to kick in
right where it's not as noisy it's not
as cluttered um
and i think you have to start looking
you know in different places so
even micro communities right that's
something that we focus on
on instagram on tiktok on twitter right
marketing to those micro communities
because we think this artist specific
audience lives in that community so just
reverse engineering stuff
how do you know it's working outside the
analytics are there little things that
you look for in the way that
a customer talks about a product or
talks about a musician uh something they
do
like like what are the little things
that you look for right so let's say
you're evaluating a startup
uh to invest in the products already out
in the market it's got a consumer facing
element to it
are there things you're looking for in
that customer base where you're like oh
when i see this like that tells me
there's really that like product market
fit people really
need this or really really want it it's
a great great question
and i didn't realize this until the past
18 months right during covid
we're selling tickets that was always a
metric for us to know what we were doing
was really working and when we lost that
i was like [ __ ] we've i relied on that a
lot i didn't realize that
it's such a commitment to buy a ticket
to see an artist live that people don't
realize right
you're maybe getting a babysitter that
night maybe you're taking off work the
next day
maybe you're getting a ride there maybe
you got to work out your public
transportation
right how like did you buy tickets three
months in advance would you buy it right
before to see if the tickets dropped
it's
the ultimate commitment that a fan can
make is seeing a live show
so that is the number one thing that
kept us going that we knew was working
every time we put out an album you put
up a tour
tour crushes we did a good job move on
right
losing that for 18 months was really
what made me realize wow i didn't
realize how much
that metric of ticket sales was
important to us
and it feels like that is uh very
similar for a startup like you're
actually
selling the product like are there sales
right just like are people willing to
take their
although you can say that appreciating
fiat currency right correct you can
actually
trade that for this good or service you
want to give up your hard-earned money
uh for this and that's the ultimate sign
that like yes i want this correct and
again it's also the similarity between
like you want to look at logic's career
in a startup
giving away free music was us it was
pre-revenue
right we weren't making any money so
everyone wants to talk about that in the
venture world oh they're pre-revenue
so were we right i was living in my
parents basement giving out
album after album for free because i
knew we were building this audience that
we'd monetize later
so that's where like there's so many
similarities between the space of
venture investing and
talent management were you guys uh
burning cds we were not at the point
that's a little bit later it's like when
apple you bought a macbook
they didn't have cd drives in them so
yeah got it so you guys would basically
be giving them out
all digitally uh like what you brought
up that piff i was gonna say
remind me what dad piff was i remember i
used to go on there for like i don't
know like lil wayne would drop a mouse
date marketplace that's what it was and
that's what we did um
you pay 50 bucks uploaded a mixtape and
they had a chart you didn't know i said
chart and that was it obviously we had
to market the music and it was all those
things where the audience was and
putting the music but the artist paid
and then it was free for everybody else
50 bucks i mean 50 bucks is nothing
right but with music it's just a massive
market opportunity and people willing to
pay and you have to believe in what
you're building because you're giving
away all your product for free
you had to believe in it and say well no
this is going to pay off right
monetizing the time is right
and that's what his first album was
that's what the first tour was and it
compounded
from there how do you think about
bitcoin the community versus like a
logic fan base right like
to me bitcoin is probably one of if not
the most
rabid engaged large audiences on the
internet right
um logic's audience is pretty similar
right you've done this for multiple
artists now right
uh what is that a sign of anything is
that like hey look like
people can look at all the prices and
the fundamentals and everything but like
the community
is like a much bigger sign than people
realize or how do you think about that
yeah you know people want to this may be
a weird comparison people want to talk
about bitcoin
failing bitcoin going to zero right i
think you and i know that's never going
to happen just based off of
the rabid people who who are believers
in it it won't go to zero because i'll
buy them all at a dollar
exactly exactly and then you have the
same thing of like
so much of like being a fan of someone
you get into barbershop debates and
that's so much of what hip-hop was and i
think logic's audience will defend him
to the death right it's a lot of that
same belief
and what that tells me is he's going to
have a career for life
we're 10 years in now right that
audience is going to be there they're
passionate they're engaged and and
that's what that tells me it gives you a
little bit of
confidence and security i think yeah and
bitcoin has that
you know times a thousand just given the
larger 100 percent
yeah and also i think that there's this
weird sense of uh
they feel like uh in music they're
protecting the artist sure
here they're protecting the network
right and the network actually can't
uh quote unquote [ __ ] up right like
logic could go out and get a dui
right or an artist could go out and do
something stupid and next thing you know
everyone's like ah
you know i don't know conor mcgregor is
probably the best example actually
loved by so many does a couple of dumb
things now some people like i don't know
how i feel
does a couple more dumb things people
may just pick all right fine like we're
done with that guy right
correct a network that is just a
computer system
that has no ability to do anything other
than what it's created to do
you don't have to worry about that right
like there's this um
almost clinical nature to it and so
there's no humanity there
uh which i've never really thought about
but like that's an interesting way to
look at like why people will be so loyal
for so long
correct like you and i were joking off
camera but like
elon could tweet whatever he wants to
tweet i shrugged my shoulders at it
it's fine he's testing it by the way he
wants to he wants to tweet whatever he
wants to tweet he's gonna do it and i
keep shrugging my shoulders it's fine
i mean he hit us with uh was it tesla
has uh diamond hands
i mean like the guy uh he understands
the internet pretty damn well right
he's a genius right but um is it genius
or is it evil genius
or are those two things the same i think
he's having fun i think the guy's a
genius and
what he's done for society and his doing
um
is incredible but i don't know
if i had that megaphone if i would
manipulate and move markets
so that's fair uh in crypto
all bitcoin or do you look at other
stuff defy all that
how do you think about it only invest in
bitcoin just bitcoin and
uh is it a thing where bitcoin is
um the core of a portfolio because
you're looking at more from like a
wealth preservation standpoint or like
how do you think about the actual
portfolio
it was a whole it was a whole bunch of
things that led up to
my conviction of bitcoin um kovid played
a massive role in what the fed did and
what happened and then i realized like
everything is just going to live on the
internet eventually everything is going
to be digitized
so if you don't think a store of value
is going to be digitized
you're out of your mind right like i'm
not buying gold i don't want to buy gold
but
have you ever bought gold i've never
bought them they're both called yeah
neither have i but i want to be able to
put
some money where it's going to be an
inflation hedge and be protected and
my belief is that that's bitcoin yeah um
now that you are into bitcoin uh
other people in your life have sort of
come into bitcoin um
friends family uh logic etc
what are those conversations like right
like come because you you have a very
unique
position in that uh you aren't
necessarily uh
full-time like my day job is in finance
uh
or venture capital or whatever but i
think when people talk to you like oh
this guy really knows what he's talking
about right he did the work
he's gone to school as you say um and
then you're talking to people
who their full-time job's not investing
either in most cases
so is that a thing where like oh they
just trust you and they're like okay hey
you know what are you doing i'll kind of
mirror that or do you find yourself like
really doing more education on kind of a
granular level uh with kind of people
outside of the finance world yeah i
would never tell anyone to blindly trust
me so i try to do some education but
again it's
surface level because some of it's
really complex especially if you don't
really understand the financial world or
how markets work
um so yeah logic was knowledgeable on it
we have another buddy of ours um that's
been around for years
who was early in the space by no means
am i trying to say i'm super early i
think
timing worked out um so yeah i try to
educate and a lot of it yeah it is
especially with clients is trust me
that's worked for me and
you know i don't say that often so um
yeah all right last thing i got to ask
you and then we'll get into rapid fire
the charizard card or whatever what what
what is going on here were you involved
in this at all
he called me and told me he was doing it
charizard
he spent a quarter million dollars on
okay and he's just a regular pokemon
card
members i don't know it's 5 30 p.m
whatever he's like yo i'm just letting
you know he's like you're not going to
talk me out of it
i'm buying a charizard card for 250
thousand dollars
i was like all right cool i was like
rocket because again when when he starts
out the phone call
i'm like yeah scissors has already been
made and i was like
i call josh josh's account i was like
call josh and listen
what's funny is he's gonna win off that
it worked right he know
he knows that world and i his intuition
is phenomenal he knows that space he
knows that world
um he and he's invested much more he
hasn't been his public about
in in the collectible trading card so
you
you've been able to help a bunch of
other people understand bitcoin and
stuff like that
uh did he convince you to go buy some
pokemon cards he has not yet
he has not yet has he tried i'm a little
bit more stubborn
has he tried he has tried you oh and
you're just not into it not having it
what
what is i'm very bullish on the space
i've made so i've made a bunch of angel
investments in the space i did
i did what not and then i introduced you
to grant i did alt
um alongside alexis ohanian who was kind
enough to let me in with him
um those those are two perfect examples
more infrastructure than hey let me go
try to figure out what cards super
bullish on the space instead of be
investing in actual cards myself yeah
i tend to think that that's a i'm with
you uh i've got a lot of friends who are
very big into it and they're like
you know not so much pokemon but more
like the sports cars like you know psa9
but i did i don't even know the
difference right
so like how could i possibly out-compete
you if you
you know all this stuff you're an expert
and i can't figure it out
for me to be willing to learn i have to
have some level of passion so when i
went to school i said i went to school
on bitcoin
i'm kind of a nerd with that kind of
stuff and it was super interesting to me
i don't have that with with collectibles
i don't really have that so i wouldn't
have
took the time to learn what cards to buy
yeah so
makes sense uh three questions to wrap
up and you guys asked me one
uh your most important book you've ever
never eat alone by keith ferrazzi okay
it completely changed my mind on
why networking it's all about networking
okay i had
i was a young kid and i thought business
was a zero-sum game
that book taught me otherwise it changed
my life what what is just the
like high level premise of the book give
and expect nothing in return
got it okay and so never eat alone means
like if you're gonna eat make sure
everyone else eats around you correct
got it uh no one's ever suggested that
before that's a great one
um second question eight sleep uh what
is your sleep schedule and for those
that don't know eight sleep is basically
a thermo-regulated bed
um i sleep on it it's [ __ ] freezing
cold
uh but i sleep like a baby do you sleep
a lot
not a lot has that changed through the
pandemic
as i've gotten older i prioritized my
sleep speaking of i just bought night
sleep
oh two weeks in that's great it's great
i'm two weeks in it's great
um i prioritize it now i did not
for for the early days and i don't
advise it i didn't sleep a lot
um i don't sleep a lot now i'm trying to
get better all right so wait two weeks
in this
this is my two questions uh did you or
did you not
get woken up by the uh vibration on the
bed the first
the first morning right it was great i
leave it on oh you oh you use it i use
it oh i had to shut it off it scares the
[ __ ] out of me no i leave it like i wake
up and i'm like
whatever right all right so yeah it's
the thermal regulation the cooling for
me yeah i'm a hot sleeper
game changer yep absolute game changer
second thing is
uh do you are you like fanatical about
hey you know a certain time every night
i go to sleep
or are you more so i go to sleep when
i'm tired but i just want to make sure i
get you know eight hours or whatever
now i'm trying to put a time to it okay
um because i can get distracted
um so midnight i try to get into bed at
midnight
um get up at 7 30. it's not bad right
and and uh if your body just gets into
it and used to it then like you're
golden
yeah and again what got me more into
trying to pay more attention to is the
the
not traveling as often traveling throws
me out of whack and i spent
a decade traveling so yeah i i hear you
yeah uh
third question aliens believer or
non-believer big believer why
i think the universe is too big for us
to be here by ourselves
that simple do you think that they're
close enough where we'll ever
come in contact or just like oh yeah
they're probably out there but we'll
just never talk to them
eventually oh you do eventually during
our lifetime
no oh all right but just like during
humanity's lifetime
100 yeah uh big question then it's just
like do we find them or do they find us
they find us you think so yeah is it
like independence day where they're like
flying down
and i don't know i haven't thought that
deep into it what do you think
in our lifetime we don't come in contact
okay um but i don't know there's a lot
of ufo
garbage that's flying around and uh
maybe some of it's real who knows
i also have to remind people that uh
ufos and aliens are not the same thing
good point right like like we just
immediately when you hear ufo you're
like oh aliens
i just watched this clip from 60 minutes
about two uh
air force pilots who swear they started
ufo
really yeah yeah but like see here's my
so like i've seen a couple of these i
haven't seen this specific one so i want
to be careful that i'm not talking about
them specifically
but like a ufo is an unidentified flying
object
so they're like i swear that i saw you a
phone you're like okay
did you see a alien spaceship or did you
just see something in the sky that you
don't know what it was
they were literally sent out to go find
out what it was because their radar was
picking it up
oh interesting yeah so like hey we see
something out there we don't know what
it is you guys fly out there
they flew out and now they're like yo it
was it was really interesting it was a
five minute segment it was really
interesting all right i'm gonna have to
watch it i'll send it to you um
you could ask me one question to finish
up
where does bitcoin end the year
uh end of year is hard how about i pick
what's the highest it hits this year
okay i should just say 100k because then
i'll uh
i'll stick with my thing um so i
definitely think it hits a hundred
if you told me sometime next year that
bitcoin hit 250 000
this year uh it wouldn't surprise me
okay
i don't know if i've got enough
confidence where i'm like it's gonna do
this
right with 100k since 2019 i've been
like this is hot like this is going to
to happen um and that's just based off
havings and kind of all that
anything over that i think it's
literally just like how
frothy is it at the time and how quickly
do we go from let's call it like 100k to
whatever right and so is that number 125
000
or 500 thousand dollars like such like a
big range in there and so i don't know
just pick the middle i got
somewhere around like 250. okay so we'll
see where
can we send people to find you on the
internet twitter
chris zuru um yeah that's where i am
is that the easiest place easiest place
founders too that's it
awesome all right well listen thank you
for doing this thank you i appreciate it
uh since i've gotten to know you i think
the uh the two things that
by far have like blown me away it's like
one the level of effort
and uh work that goes into just like
building a fan base that's actually
engaged and like people are like yo i
[ __ ] love like whatever this thing is
and then two uh there's not very many
people who like
start in that world and like hey i'm
gonna go learn this other world right
there's a lot of people who start out
here they have success in the music
world or whatever and then they're like
oh yeah well like i'm successful like of
course i just you tell me what to do
i think you started out and you said
look i don't know that much right and
over the last couple of years you've
like really built yourself up in terms
of like now you could go and you could
sit down and talk to anybody
oh this guy knows who's doing so kudos
to you appreciate that
uh i appreciate everyone listening and
we will do this again in the future
thank you